hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
Jeffrey Skilling was the lovely
character that we were introduced to in
the last episode of ColdFusion after his
time at Enron the ex CEO was sentenced
to 24 years in prison and fined 45
million dollars for his role in the
largest corporate fraud in history as
mentioned in the last video
he's freshly out of jail and planning a
return let's see what he's been up to
[Music]
in 2010 skilling gave a rare interview
to a fortune reporter in the interview
he still defended the company's
rationale in how they used to mark to
market accounting to inflate revenue he
was still angry Randy foster for ratting
out to the investigators and also his
criminal actions of using specially made
sub companies to soak up Enron debts and
hide losses skilling appeared to be
humbled in prison the CEO who was once
worth 110 billion dollars was in the
strange and ironic position where he
wasn't even allowed to physically touch
any money not even a few quarters and
change with embarrassment
skilling asked the reporter could you
blame me a cup of coffee
inmates aren't allowed to touch any
money or approach the machines they
could put me in solitary confinement for
a week
one of Skilling's biggest regrets was
talking too much during the trial
instead of pleading the fifth amendment
his lawyer told him to stay silent but
he didn't he thought he could talk his
way out skilling said that this educated
the jury on information that they would
have otherwise had to make up their own
mind about he went on to say that this
mistake compromised his case after
serving 12 years of a sentence he was
recently released from a
minimum-security federal prison to a
halfway house at an undisclosed location
a halfway house is a highly restricted
dormitory like establishment that helps
federal inmates ease back into society
inmates must maintain curfews find work
and stay out of trouble
so how much money did he get away with
it's unclear how much money skilling has
of that 100 million dollars he made at
Enron under his conviction he was
ordered to pay 42 million dollars and
his court costs and legal defense cost
another 20 million so he could have up
to 38 million dollars with that money he
should just lay low well as you know
from the title of this video and the
previous episode skilling had other
ideas during his time at the halfway
house skilling was already thinking of
his next business and had already
started having meetings for the new
project currently he's back in Houston
working out of an office in a wealthy
executive neighborhood that
coincidentally also is home to some of
the energy industry's richest executives
skilling has already met with more than
two dozen four men on executives
according to an insider the former CEO
has had a warm reception according to
The Wall Street Journal
skilling has also met with software
developers and blockchain and
cryptocurrency specialists this
indicates that this new venture might
involve a digital cryptographic platform
which connects investors to energy
projects though all of this is
unconfirmed and that's an underlying
issue the main nature of the project is
something of a mystery people in contact
with Jeffrey Skilling have signed
non-disclosure agreements according to
two insiders Lau PI the stripper
obsessed Enron executive remained close
with skilling following the collapse and
throughout his time in prison Lau PI
made approximately 300 million dollars
and is said that he's using some of that
money to help out skilling only two
months after his released from prison in
April of 2019 skilling was listed as a
manager of a company called JKL 1990 LLC
on the Texas Registry another company by
the name of paper doll style LLC is
owned by Skilling's daughter and will be
a professional partner according to the
National Post there's reason to believe
that these two companies are set up for
the sole purpose of raising money and
finding ventures to invest in
as mentioned in the previous episode as
part of the SEC judgment Jeffrey
Skilling is permanently barred from
serving as an officer or director of any
publicly held company former US
prosecutor Peter Henning states quote
even if his new venture is successful he
cannot serve on its board and am i crimp
is fundraising
the problem with skilling is that you
may not want to be seen investing with
him
unquote and that's the obvious problem
for skilling he would want to work with
one of the biggest convicted fraudsters
in history but then again the economic
world is a strange place these days
investors are searching for yield
anywhere they can and that makes
anything possible ultimately we'll have
to wait and see as a side note I found
something mildly interesting during my
research I found an archive of many of
Jeffrey's killings emails at Enron I
don't think there's anything damning
here for instance this is an email of
Jeffrey Skilling asking people what they
thought of is beated but it is just a
little piece of history to look at I'll
leave a link for the archive below so
that's all the information that we know
about what's the killing is up to these
days it's all very secretive but it's
clear that it's planning something on
the topic of fraud there's talk and
whispers that a similar thing to Enron
is happening with General Electric I'm
waiting for more concrete details to
emerge but if some news does break I
might do an episode on it anyway if
that's about it thanks for watching this
has been - go go and you've been
watching cold fusion don't forget to
check out the cold fusion podcast I'll
leave a link for that below and feel
free to follow me on Twitter and
Instagram cheers guys
have a good one
cold fusion is he thinking
[Music]
you